knocks it away good Hustle by Zach
Levine
great effort by Levine Charlotte got a
technical foul because they did not
believe they did not believe that
tomorrow got fouled ball was the one who
got the technical foul
he was drawing away with the referees a
couple nights ago in Milwaukee too he
was imitating like pantomiming the
officials saying you should call a
technical foul and was like pantomiming
the T and pantomiming the whistle so you
can't really do that I know lamelo's a
confident young man but you got teed up
that time but I will say this this game
is about emotion is it yeah I agree with
you take that into consideration you
know these athletes man have you know
they they have feelings too you got I
mean as long as they're not
disrespectful it didn't look like uh
lamella was doing a whole lot he's just
saying I got fat on the other hand you
gotta call that these some of these
officials man I mean don't make it
personal you know these kids
it's an emotional game you've got to let
them have some emotions sometimes as
long as it's not disrespectful they're
cursing you out and they're in your face
all right lamello just got teed up again
that's uh that's that first one was
tough obviously once you get the first
you can't keep going but the first one I
agree with you was a little tough on
lamelo ball just let him play I mean
it's a minute 21 seconds left the people
want to see the people come here to see
the Bulls they also have come to see the
star players on other teams unless it's
just